you're like family i know i i feel like
i've just come home yeah you pulled a
prank on carlos when he visited you on
set
i don't think he's over that do you
remember that yeah that was good you saw
cheryl over the weekend at the ccma yeah
how are you doing i'm good it's good to
be here it's so nice to be home i uh i
miss i miss canada so much people it's
just
you know i feel like my life is just
always on the road you know yeah i'm
talking about the road highway 99
congratulations on your debut album i
mean has it sunk in that it's out there
now
yeah i mean
i don't know like it's some
i can't remember who asked me this they
were like
so what's like making that transition
i'm like i still feel like i'm making
that transition to be honest like
the first
real experience i feel like i've had was
playing in calgary at the palace and
there's like a thousand people there and
i didn't know how i was going to be
received you know doing this you know
you see so many actors going
and musicians going kind of back and
forth and it either works or rubs people
the wrong way and i just wanted to come
from a place of authenticity and the
crowd was nuts i've never i never could
have expected that in my wildest dreams
so it's it's an amazing pl way to start
and i'm i'm really excited people seem
to be liking what we're doing because
it's a wicked album it's such a great
vibe and my favorite song is malibu blue
amazing i love the vibe of that song so
i think that's the reason but music has
been part of your life for so long
yeah it's actually uh insane how how
this all happened i when i was 10 years
old my mom convinced a guy who worked at
this
music store tommy lee music store in
north vancouver to um
to
to teach me how to play guitar because i
was begging her for a guitar guitar
lesson she's my biggest fan and she
supported me this whole way she really
is she's i wouldn't be here without her
and um
every week he would teach me how to play
and just i would be playing guitar to my
fingers bled and writing music
and
he moved to nashville started playing
for brett eldredge who's a close buddy
of mine
and
i told him when i was a kid one day when
i got my record deal we're gonna play
together and the greatest call of my
life was two years ago when i got my
deal i called jesse and i was like dude
it's happening we're doing this so he's
with me right now and
um it's just a surreal experience to be
to be doing
two things that i love
simultaneously i just feel like the
luckiest guy in the world you're killing
it you're killing it i love it
congratulations i mean your mom must be
so proud she is she's really really
proud i mean it's tough like you know
i'm sure you know this as well with your
job it's like
it's it's hard balancing family life and
and your life on the road um
but it is a very uh at the end of the
day it's like i should be so lucky to be
even able to say that sentence you know
and be able to do both so
um she is really proud i miss them i
know and being on the road highway 99
that must be a reason for the name was
because of your family and you're
driving on highway 99 in vancouver yeah
highway 99 for those who don't know it's
it's also called the cedar sky highway
it's a two-lane road from um vancouver
to whistler and whistler is one of my
favorite places in the world my family
had a cabin there it's where i learned
how to play
it's where i wrote my first song so
my whole country music education really
happened on that road you know and
um i was just like it's only fitting to
call your first album give it a little
nod to my my hometown and that road in
specific
do you use music in a way to help you
like emotionally and mentally to kind of
write down what you're going through has
that been a journey for you with music
totally i mean
music especially as a kid like was a way
was an outlet for me like it was my
therapy you know whenever i was dealing
with stuff as as a kid
that would be my outlet and
i think over the years
especially it's a totally different
experience when you're in a writer's
room like in nashville with some of the
most talented writers on the planet some
of the best storytellers on the planet
so much of it is personal experience but
then also
it can be their personal experience and
sometimes being a great writer is
actually just sitting back and and
listening
and going you know we don't have to go
with my idea today what's your idea and
hearing about that experience going wow
like that's really interesting and then
the coolest thing about music is you
literally go into a room with a bunch of
people you barely know and you make
something out of nothing yeah yeah what
has been your most personal
song
i mean it's funny like
it's a love-hate relationship with all
my music i've heard them all so much
that like i think i go in waves which my
what my favorite is
but
the most personal has to be let me be
your whiskey
and that was one of the first songs i
actually wrote when i got to nashville
and the reason i have this deal or why
i'm sitting here talking about music
today is um
that song
is so personal just because
i sat across a room with a guy named
mike delaney he's a tremendous writer in
nashville he wrote the way you love me
for faith hill and tattoos on this town
for jason aldean
and um we were sitting there and i was
just like man we all use these like
things to like
to to make us feel a certain way or feel
better like what if that person
can be that um
for the guy who's singing it you know
and
i was like let me be here like and of
course like mike is
just straight up cowboy he is the
coolest and he's like what about let me
be a whiskey and i was like
yes
um so we started writing that and
obviously i've had my own experiences
with substance abuse and all of that and
i loved a different take
on that you know um
so that was it really meant a lot and i
didn't realize how many people were
gonna love that song i i sent it out and
people were like dude this is
like i really really like this it's a
really fresh take on it so
yeah
nicki minaj heard the song
i mean can we even show any of that
video on our sh our show have you seen
the video yeah have you seen what you've
been doing on the video i felt like
i um
you know what's so funny it's like tell
me everything i was like i'm not even
gonna talk about this like i'm just
gonna do it and then just like
nobody's gonna like bring it up and i
have been asked about this video
every interview um
how this happened is wild okay i
okay so when i was when i was going to
college
you're blushing a little bit here well
it's just it's such i'm blushing because
like okay i went into the present of the
label and i was like john john like i
got uh i got something to tell you and
he's like
what
it's like i'm not gonna feel like i said
i got a music video coming out he's like
yeah i'm like with nicki minaj she's
like why what's wrong with that i was
like well it's not country and he's like
dude it's awesome um
but uh you know he only lived once and
i'm a huge fan of her music and she was
a fan of of me and her team was a fan of
me so it was like it was just a great uh
a great experience i mean it's like what
a cool story she's so cool she's amazing
and um
but
how this happened was that
my former freshman year college roommate
was going to be an engineer he was like
this awkward guy
um
at the time and now he's just and i was
just a train wreck right and i was like
dude
you don't have to be an engineer like i
know it because he always talked about
movies and i was like you gotta gotta
get into film and television he ends up
dropping out
his parents probably hated me yeah he
drops out he gets in the film and now
he's producing the biggest music videos
in hollywood so he called me
uh while i was in whistler funny enough
with some friends and he's like i really
need your help we need a guy for this
video it's kind of
barbie and ken meets mr and mrs smith
and blah blah and i was like
yeah man like i'll do i'll do whatever
for you and this is this is cool i've
never like done anything like this and
i feel like you can't take yourself too
seriously no you know so much fun but i
was like i watched it last night like i
don't even know if we could show any of
this
[Applause]
even you went for it
i mean you have to even when i even when
i saw the video i was like oh yeah wow
same reaction there you go
i can see you guys collaborating
together would you ever do that with
nikki yeah 100 i think she's yeah i mean
i think she's really she's i think
arguably the most talented female rapper
ever
um she's done so much for women in that
in that business and
um i mean we we got along great so
100 i mean i think i like to see the
super freaky girl movie
i think would definitely be rated r but
that'd be an interesting one uh let's
put it out i think for now just a music
video but we'll see
uh another person i saw that's an
incredible woman is jennifer lawrence
during tiff oh she was here yeah she was
here for causeway she has a film that's
out and it got me thinking about the
prequel to hunger games are you excited
about it
it's so funny like i haven't even like i
saw like they had announced that but i
guess i've it's been so it's so funny
it's been so long and i still have
people that come up to me being like
their kids love the hunger games and
it's like
i can't even believe they know about
that movie
um
and
even though i've done so much since then
i feel like
that's still a really important film for
me for so many reasons and
um so yeah like i'm really excited for
that film but i feel like i've also
it's been so long that i i almost like
didn't even like put the two together
like
it's like it just seems like it's going
to be its own movie that's like
different from from everything but like
my kids are being introduced to hunger
games right now that's why yeah i mean
it's only good for us i mean that's
great like
if people end up watching the first film
because of that that's awesome and
i mean it changed my life it's reason i
got vikings and vikings really changed
my life so um i'm so grateful for that
film
and you're also working on another
project the interpreter yeah with with
jake gyllenhaal
amazing i mean guy richie is um
literally the one of the few directors
that like i think is probably a
household name and also just
um
one of the few directors who made me
want to be an actor growing up you know
like really oh yeah lock stock into
smoking barrels or snatch some of my
favorites um he is such an authentic
style and he's
the coolest dude um you could imagine i
mean so so awesome like i always very
you know they always say don't meet your
heroes um like
very far and few between have i met
people and just been like you're above
and beyond what i could have ever
imagined he's one of them he's just like
wow what an awesome dude and we have a
great relationship and i hope to do a
lot more with him so from music to
movies to heels season two with stephen
like
you're so busy yeah how excited are you
about season two of heels
that's completely different from
everything else i find i'm so excited i
mean
i think the show's fantastic and i'm
that's the reason i i did it is it's so
different from anything i've ever done
and i loved the story so much
the writing is phenomenal i think the
cast is amazing they all brought you
know their a game um
it's interesting though like
there's so much out there
in in like just the zeitgeist right now
that
that you know
i think it just takes a minute for a
small
wrestling show
you know which is so much more than that
but but to really take notice but the
people who have seen it
seem to flip for it and i'm so
so grateful for that as well i mean
vikings took like four seasons before
anybody even knew who we were right yeah
it's interesting big show yeah are you
guys competitive you and steven like
who's stronger who's who does better
who's more fit we like we joke around on
a ton like while we're while we're
filming and i mean when it comes to
stunts we definitely try to one-up each
other
um which can be dangerous i mean i
the
you can't fake it in this show so
um we obviously have amazing stone
doubles who do things that
there's no way a producer will
sign off on us unless you know we're tom
cruise and you just go yeah i'm doing it
um so like we
like if you're falling off of a cage
that's like 20 feet in the air like
they're gonna have a stunt double do
that but
all the wrestling is us so
the back flips that you see me do off
the top turnbuckle that's something i
had to learn how to do and when we're
superplexing each other we're doing that
so it's um
it's
it's very hard on your body and i'm like
i don't know how these
my respect for these people in this
industry are just it's through the roof
because it's basically like
the same schedule as a musician
and then just like
getting hit on the head with a guitar
every night
it's wild
you